hello and welcome to the lobby game spa
it's weekly hangout every tuesday at 2pm
pacific right here on gamespot.com how
you doing i'm daniel mcguire joined by
scott butterworth and andy bauman still
taking notes
such as the professionalism we have on
offer here he's just doodling i'm just
looking nothing it's just
he's like don't talk about gamers under
embargo we can get through this whole
show without mentioning we'll be doing
challenges
you know what game is nothing your
embargo that we're here to talk about
though
the need for speed we're just getting
right into it yeah through that banter
we're just going right for the
need for speed yeah it's a game it's
just called need for speed right it's
just called need for speed what is the
closest need for speed it is to though
in relation to the old need for speed
games sure uh it's it's kind of like
underground okay so the never speed
underground games were like the tuner
street racing kind of games and this
came out in 2003 and 2004 i believe
and it's not it's not exactly like those
games but it is sort of about you know
tuner culture again and it's about
illegal street racing and you know it's
always nighttime you're building up your
own tuner mobile and so it's similar to
those but it actually feels like driving
wise and mechanically feels a lot like
hot pursuit actually oh really uh or
most wanted i think either of those it's
definitely not shift it's not like the
realistic need for speeds like those
were their own thing and it's not even
too much like rivals which was the first
need for speed from ghost games who also
made this need for speed so you gave an
8 out of 10 on gay spots the review is
currently up right now it's true um talk
a little bit about the sort of the the
the time you hit a wall because i found
that to be an interesting part of your
review you kind of tried to make a you
know master of all trades uh or jack of
all trades master of non-car and it
didn't quite work out yeah exactly i
mean that and that's exactly what
happened um i was actually kind of
struggling with how to start the review
and what i wanted to talk about and then
i realized that
the moment that sort of stuck out to me
was was that realization of even though
i had some serious trouble with the
difficulty spike late in the game i
still wanted to play i mean once i got
past that and the game became fun again
it was like i was oh great this is you
know um and ultimately that's that's
sort of what decided the score for me um
i mean even when i sat down to write the
review i was kind of torn between a
seven and an eight you know for a lot of
the reasons that i'm sure we're gonna
get into but ultimately why i decided on
an eight was
i mean two things one a lot of the
problems that people have at the game
are arguably fleeting stuff that's only
to
affect a small portion of the game and
stuff that's really good is going to
continue to be good things like the
driving and the customization things
like that those would be good in
perpetuity but the other big thing was
like i said i i always wanted to keep
playing i mean no matter what
i came up against in the game i was
always excited to continue driving to
continue upgrading my vehicle and and
any game that can do that even if i if i
want to go play a game after i'm done
reviewing it that's a powerful thing so
in spite of its foibles it still brought
you back exactly what were you doing
when you came back what type of
activities do you sort of what is the
meat and potatoes in need for speed sure
it's a little all over the place um you
know there's drift events there's racing
events there's gymkhana which combines
like a lot of different driving
disciplines uh and it's you know it's an
open world structured game kind of like
burnout paradise or you know any number
of previous need for speed games um so
you can just pick and choose the events
you like and kind of do those and
eventually you will
kind of be forced to do a little of
everything if you want to continue to
progress through the story um but it's
pretty open you have a lot of options um
actually there's one thing i really
wanted to talk about one of the biggest
problems people had with the game was
rubber banding ai which is kind of a
dirty word and when it comes to racing
games and something that is all too
frequent and you know it comes up a lot
in racing games right
um and it is a problem it is annoying
and i'm bummed that this game has pretty
obvious rubber banding but here's the
thing one it didn't completely ruin the
experience and two it only affects a
small portion of the events in the game
i mean a lot of the events you're
competing against to clock or trying to
reach a point total things like that
only a small handful have you competing
directly against ai competitors um so
the rubber banding ai doesn't affect the
entire game it just affects a small
portion and yeah it sucks that it's
there but for me i was able to work
through and get past it yeah we noticed
some of that when we were we did our um
gamespot plays yeah i started right now
playing last weekend that was fun it was
a good it was good live stream it was
good fun andy did you place after you uh
we did that live stream like what is
your main takeaway from new speed as
somebody who plays like a bunch of the
forza game coming from that sort of
angle yeah i mean like
point blank you should play forza
horizon 2.
but like it's a very different game it's
yeah but it's like it's got all this
stuff in it and more so it's like i
don't know but the thing about need for
speed is we were playing on xbox one yes
uh one thing to note is like the ps4
version was running way smoother the
whole like overall and it almost like
was catching my eye in certain places
where it looked better right so i don't
know if how much of a like widespread
thing that is or if there's a patch that
fixes that uh day one
but like that's something to look out
for that's interesting because we did
have like pretty frequent frame rate
hitching on the xbox one and not that it
was like completely unplayable
but it was definitely like a noticeable
thing and that's uh that's a key thing
but
yeah i would agree like
it's not bad like there's nothing
terrible that's going to turn you off
about it and the rubber banding ai
actually
uh is nice in a way because like on
these street race stuff the streets are
empty yeah because they kind of took out
all the traffic which is nice for the
game play aspect because you don't want
to run into random cars like which does
happen sometimes but yeah if it was
happening all the time you would just
break your disc in half like the crew
that happens all the time and you just
want to kill yourself yeah because it's
not your fault it's just yeah it just
comes up also and you're saying why why
would you put something in the commuter
so and then like the drift events like
you're saying it doesn't matter yeah and
also like it helps because you get drift
trains if you kind of like sync your
drift with all your dudes yeah yeah and
it's all about the style like you're not
racing against them you're racing like
with them to like put down the best you
know drift turns on the on the
switchy-backy turns of the mountains so
it's like yeah it's it's probably cool
it's called the switchy-backy things
yeah switchy-backy and the in tuner
culture that's the i think yeah i'm sure
okay go for it yeah well yeah like
one of the things we both kind of were
talking about that we liked is it forces
you to tune your car and it gives you
the like
the meta slider that just says
drift grip or drift if you want to
ignore everything just there's a master
slider at the very top that like do you
want a grippy card you want a drift card
you don't have to think about anything
yeah but i would sincerely recommend
diving into the more like granular
things that you can adjust you can kind
of see it on screen right there let's
see yeah handbrake strength and spring
stiffness and like all the stuff
actually matters and it will impact the
way the game controls so if you are
playing the game like i hate how this
handles go adjust stuff like it handles
the way you want it to handle just go
mess with it and make it into what you
want it to be yeah it was interesting
you tuned your car differently and then
did a drift event and it was like a
no-go oh yeah i was like i got to redo
this yeah
it took me like an embarrassingly long
time to figure that out and like i said
the game almost encourages you to just
build up a single car like the way the
progression system is structured and
the rate at which currency is meted out
it really encourages you to build up one
car
early on at least and so later when i
hit the wall that you had mentioned
earlier basically what happened was i
could no longer get away with having one
car i needed to have multiple cars or at
least drastically re-tune my car for
each different event which was a giant
pain by the way it's better to have two
cars if you can afford it did you ever
get the ferrari f40 because there's
nothing like that oh yeah i i bought the
uh uh i'm not gonna say it right so i'm
used to reading it that the lamborghini
aventador okay uh it's like the second
highest rated car in the game but i
preferred it over the highest rated and
yeah like once you have enough money you
can buy the crazy exotic cars like
they're absolutely in the game but
really it's it's about building up your
stock like nothing car into something
really cool and that's a little more
rewarding okay okay let's talk about
i feel like we talked about this a
couple of weeks ago when we had you on
with guitar hero yes fmv man yeah
it's back in a bit 2015.
i think cameras have gotten good this is
like a camera nerd thing yeah yeah but i
think like cameras have gotten so good
that they can run these like deep focal
length lenses and not and make it like
lit in a way that's not like super over
the top and it looks kind of kind of
natural like it's obviously supplemented
you can you can see hmis going through
windows in this game and stuff but like
it looks nice like i think it's cool and
it's like impressive that they do these
things they have like probably like
you know use
motion tracking in the shots like
robotic tracking or or it's just a
steady really good steady camera like
it's like it's so impressive it looks
like kooky but it's good good right yeah
and it's they're obviously shooting like
you know ultra hd like 4k 5k 6k so it's
like damn this stuff is like but then
the acting is like yeah i hadn't even
thought about the the camera nerd aspect
of it it was really fascinating talking
to andy about it because like that's
kind of what andy does and so i hadn't
even it occurred to me that the way it
was made was actually kind of cool
because yeah i was a little more fixated
on like the acting and the dialogue
which are not great um
in guitar hero
it was like really
insufferable and just like
i don't know like i just i really
couldn't stand it in guitar hero but for
whatever reason it really grew on me
here um i think because it's just kind
of like friendly and goofy and really
welcoming in a weird way and it just
kind of won me over like it's
there's no discernible plot like there's
no like arching storyline there's
nothing it's a comprehensive it's like a
bunch of people meeting who apparently
are all like streetcar racers kind of
never meeting near cars like always yeah
all right
exactly like there's one scene that
happens in with like cars present
everything else is like ah maybe there's
a car in the background but it's like
shooting outdoors expensive yeah exactly
they needed sets and then when they did
try to bring like the models of the
in-game cars into the shots you can
really see the seams of the green room
yeah yeah the green screen stuff so i
mean like i said it it won me over and
it's like charming campiness and and i
wasn't gonna really penalize the game
too deeply even if it was bad because
it's a racing game like i'm not really
playing racing games for story like i
just and you can skip everything by the
way if you really are grossed out by the
idea of fmvs you can absolutely just
skip everything and you still get all
the same events you can still play the
game exactly the same so you don't have
to experience any of that but if you sit
through it it might win you over like it
won me over because it is just like
goofy and fun and like you just get to
know and love these stupid characters uh
so i i actually grew to really enjoy it
which is kind of like what never speed
underground was as well it was this like
dumb like character
like that's kind of in fitting with it
in a way so i mainly just remember like
under glow and all that kind of stuff
that was that was my you know fond
memories of underground uh let's talk
about the final point i want to talk
about because it for some reason it's
one of my favorite aspects of this game
and at the start i thought it was like
super kooky and weird but the fact that
this game is in like perpetual night
time
yeah well so underground was was all at
night as well so it's sort of in keeping
with that i mean you know it's illegal
street racing right like what illegal
street race is happening in the middle
of the day 3 p.m yeah i mean like it's
not generally i imagine how those sorts
of things are conducted not really you
know i'm not much of a gear head i
haven't spent a lot of time oh we know
we're racing cars weekend's gone yeah
it's it's not racing cars though or oil
underneath his fingers yeah oh clearly
yeah
really a tuner i changed my headlight
this weekend what did you really tuned
out because you've been playing the [ __ ]
out of it yeah man
i actually had to go back because i
bought the wrong one
yeah you didn't change your headlight
you replaced your headlights yeah oh
yeah because you were there when it was
yeah i was like wait have you been
driving around for like a month i don't
drive my car okay okay only on weekends
and during the day but what i love about
the nighttime stuff is that like it in
certain parts of the map it's like dawn
yeah it starts to get a little dusky and
then it's immediately nighty and then
you go past like a point in the level
and it goes like fade in fade out yeah
so it's like you're playing in like
alaska or something like it's like oh
it's daytime for 30 minutes and we're
back again like we kind of rushed on how
it looks good or like the night driving
it looks [ __ ] cool
it's beautiful the game is absolutely
gorgeous as well yeah yeah
i get that people think that it's it's
kind of dumb that it's always wet and
always night but god it's it's gorgeous
i just love whipping around the world
it's just so much fun just to drive
around and look at everything it's
beautiful it's it's one of the best
looking racing games i've ever played
and last point honest um i just want to
touch on before we wrap up multiplayer
stuff how does that work is it essential
is it non-essential like so you're in a
sort of shared open world i mean like i
said you're in a big city it's an open
world map uh and within that map uh you
will find other drivers it's it's always
online which is its own its own thing i
called it out in the review because i
knew that for some people that's a deal
breaker like always online no out and
like burn it to the ground i want
nothing to do with it instantly and for
me it wasn't a deal breaker like it's
annoying for the reasons i outlined in
the review like you can't pause stuff
like that and yeah it's i don't like it
but i learned to live with it oh yeah
that's why we're going to the map yes
and your car just keeps going he went
into the map and the car is just like
going down the street
because it's always online you you can't
pause the game like if you need to the
joke i made in the reviews if you need
to stop your cat from destroying your
furniture you can't you're either gonna
lose the event or your cat's gonna
destroy your couch it's like you can't
actually pause the game always online is
annoying for a lot of reasons that's one
of them but again for me not a deal
breaker called it out so people can make
up their own minds if they hate it fine
great um but yes multiplayer you can
create crews and have your friends join
events with you you can just cruise
around the map and find people there and
challenge them to sort of ad hoc events
by just pulling up next to them and
pulling one of the triggers or one of
the bumpers um yeah so there are plenty
of options there's no dedicated
multiplayer mode but i didn't have a
problem jumping into events and having
fun with people actual human beings not
rubber banding ai any benefits of that
was there like extra cash rewards uh if
you beat a friend's time it'll
specifically mark events where a friend
has set a high score or a best time and
if you go to that event and you beat
their time you get more
rep experience and more cash than you
would have if it was just a regular
event so the game does reward you for
beating your friends times and playing
sort of asynchronously right so just
make sure your friends suck and need for
speed exactly good to go sorry there's
no cockpit cam no manual shifting that's
true not a lot of options which as like
i'm an arcadey like need for speed fan i
like the burnout games i like big
crashes and going fast so stuff like
manual shifting and and cockpit view
don't really matter to me um i mentioned
a couple of them in the review just so
people would know but for me i'm just
there to go fast like i don't need
shifting it didn't affect me i don't
care um but for some people i know that
that's a deal-breaker so now you know
you can make up your own minds readers
good info viewers watchers whoever um
yeah so that's need for speed sweet andy
scott thank you so much absolutely
talking about race cars uh presumably
this is back to being an annualized
franchise we may see you guys once a few
months to talk about all again and let
us know what you think of need for speed
uh you are a fan of the series you want
to get back into it or is this one
piqued your interest for the first time
or do you are you not into it do you
have another racing game du jour you're
enjoying it let us know in the comment
box below alright we got bunch more
stuff to talk about today we're going to
talk about
goddamn candy crush in a while we're
going to talk about rise of the tomb
raider since that embargo has officially
dropped and we're going to talk about
fallout 4's
controllers uh at the end of the show as
well we'll be back in a second gonna
check out this hot first look trailer at
kursk really
submarines
you
uh
rise of the tomb raider is just around
the corner the second part in the
trilogy we weren't supposed to know
about and we've got mary katie and
luxory korea on the couch who've been
playing it for the past week or so yeah
all right exactly any of you doing the
review
that's mike some of us doing a review
all right so we can get real dig into
dirty about what you guys think about
tomb raider um alexa first of all how
are you enjoying this you a fan of the
old game what do you think of this one i
actually i really liked the reboot i
really liked the way that they sort of
set it up as you are building laura like
this is how she becomes this badass
archaeologist and i'm really liking the
game a lot i think that level design's
great uh how does it play in really is
it very familiar to the the reboot game
which came out
2013. 2013 okay so they're coming up on
three on them yeah because it was early
2013 as well i think yeah so it's
actually been a while yeah the best way
to compare it is if you liked that one
you're going to like this one more
because they took everything that you
would have liked about it and they
doubled down on it so what are we
talking about is it um being able to
customize the lara with upgrades to
skill points they've like doubled the
amount of skills that she has now you
can actually choose
what kind of lara you have as opposed to
just one type of lara there's more
weapon customization there's more
weapons in general and the world is more
open instead of linear
in the first game it was
it was open and it was not it was linear
you were going down one way in this game
they are putting you in an area where
there's lots of different stuff to mess
with or you can do the story so there is
more choice in this game so there's kind
of like there is one path for the main
quest which you can see but
there's more like stuff around the edges
that you're sort of you can go ahead and
definitely because i had a bit on the
first one but it was kind of only those
those individual tombs it was like two
things they were like optional tombs and
they told you that and it was very it
wasn't you know you didn't really get
anything for them either like this one
is you get like special skills that you
can only get if you complete
certain tunes yeah and if you don't do
the tombs you don't have to do the tombs
but you don't get the skill so here
there's a lot of incentive to like go
off and explore and find stuff so what
are those tombs like how do they play
are you on your own generally is it
because a lot of the like i guess
maybe one of the criticisms that i had
about the old game although it was like
really good sorry the reboot was that
you were shooting a lot of people and
killing a lot of people whereas tomb
raider was always kind of a more
solitary game of exploration and killing
animals
so like are those tombs do do they have
the bombast of the main quest stuff or
is it more solitary like puzzles and
whatnot yeah they're puzzles
they're very more puzzles and there's
more puzzles there is a lot of killing
there's no way to say that there's not
um i always associated lara with killing
i mean when i played uh tomb raider
2 or any of the ones like back on the on
like the old pc like yeah or a
playstation she killed a lot of people
with guns this one is just more vivid
it's more real she's shooting in the
face she's um stabbing them in the
throat poisoning them it's more
aggressive
but she killed people before yeah this
has not changed she's just a little bit
more it's a little bit more gruesome but
you should expect that right it's a more
visually stimulating game it's more
right it's more interesting so yeah the
the death scenes are more intense but
they're not as crazy as the reboot one
right because like that was one of those
things where people were like oh man you
can really watch this lady get killed in
[ __ ] up ways like
a lingering camera that kind of was kind
of staying there definitely they toned
them down a little bit but she still
gets eaten like a tiny she gets eaten
there's one where she falls on spikes
and like the spike goes like up through
her jaw for her cheek it's like it's
really really
still there but i think they've toned it
down a little bit i don't think the
developers wanted this game to be
associated with her being impaled in the
gut and stuff like that um i'm sure a
lot of people will remember there were
two scenes in the original reboot one
where she's like going down a a flood
landslide
and if
i did like five times in a row not
because i wanted to see it but because
that that like it almost felt quick
timing it was like i left to write do i
go up there no no no no no no no
there's not a lot of that quick timey
stuff on this one either they've they've
reduced it there's still stuff but i
would say it's less there's uh and then
there's less of those if you don't hit x
you are you see this gross shot it
doesn't happen but you will there's
still elements of her dying
um if you make the wrong mistake and
hurt killing dudes too how does it look
that first game i remember thinking it
looked real good had all the tress
effects stuff in it that's still here
it's not trust effects it's called like
hair powers there's so many different
hair power they have been updated
yeah i would say i love to compare it's
like the witcher because like she could
be
500 feet underground in a cave with no
air and her hair is like blowing
beautifully it makes no sense but like
that's the way the witcher was too but i
liked the way his hair looked and i like
the way her hair looks it's very natural
and and
it's cool like they've done a lot with
it and it's not just her hair
you know she's just they've done extra
touches to her when she is close to a
wall she touches it when she's cold you
can see her lip quiver they've done a
lot of little things that i think make
her look
genuine yeah and like if you look really
really close the developers were telling
us in the first game she gets hit in the
face with like the butt of a gun and if
you look really close at her character
model there's a scar there all right so
she has like pieces of like like her
history carried like physically on her
and that's neat she really feels like
she's
like we're seeing the same alarm from
the last game we're feeling like she's
available she's gonna have for the next
game going to be disgusting she'll just
be like covered in bandages and she'll
have one eye
so what are the types of environments
that you guys experience then how much
of the game have you played like
generally like and what what type of
environments we looking at because the
first game was very much the tropical
island sort of thing yeah and that kind
of sucked right because you're like
seeing the same thing every time this
one there's all sorts of stuff yeah you
have snow and then woods and desert
deserts yeah like they've shown them in
like underwater
there's a lot of water she can swim she
can swim this time so you can swim
around now could she not swim in the
first game nope oh really and she can
kill people underwater which we saw a
little bit of um
i was telling alex i was bummed because
in the previous tomb raider games like
way back in the day water always had
like sharks and like barracudas and like
messed up stuff that would kill you
there's like nothing in the water so the
water's just fine you know there's no
scariness in the water so no t-rex then
in this one either no
not as far i mean who knows
like the first tomb raider get the first
reboot uh everything was like oh this is
pretty cool and then all of a sudden it
was like aliens and ghosts and you're
like all right now it's now it's [ __ ]
weird but like in this one we don't know
yet but currently it's very grounded
it's not as it's subtle i mean the first
one went places too like the first game
ended up with some real [ __ ]
strangers yeah like spooky ghost stuff
as well at some point they're just like
you know what let's put her in space
i just didn't think it didn't even care
lara x jason coming soon um let's talk a
little bit about that there's some micro
transaction stuff in here as well what
does that take the form of yeah people
were pretty angry and i think a lot of
that is they
they were
you hear that word and there's
aggression yeah yeah it's a it's paid
away it's a wrong number people say yeah
um that's not so the microtransactions
here i think we're actually looking at
them yeah i did some screen cap of it
this just to show you guys what it looks
like yeah this is uh you earn so you
earn credits by completing challenges
you earn these in-game credits and you
spend them on card packs and the card
packs unlock weapons and gear to be used
only in the expedition mode of the game
what's expedition mode it's not it's ah
it's not like multiplayer it's a
challenge mode that you complete
yourself but you're competing like with
other people for like high scores or you
can set up or you can go to a previous
area and set yourself a condition like
i'm gonna get through here in
two minutes or whatever and you just
sort of race yourself sort of like
isolated zones yeah
yeah off of the main game that's right
so you cannot spend any
human money that in any way will impact
the story yeah but you can spend human
money to
get maybe increase your chance of
getting on the top of a friend's
leaderboard yeah
it's all about that but there's nowhere
in the game where you can like buy money
and then go in and be like oh i want
like this item like like there's no
that's just not there sweet i'd love to
know who buys this stuff because like
some stuff is like like cards it's like
okay you know like i get like ultimate
team i get why people might get into
that because they spend so much time
with it but like why would you buy to
get you know to boost yourself in a
multiplayer thing that just seems like i
don't know if they somebody's doing it
right they wouldn't do it if people
didn't pay for it and i understand that
if people don't like it
uh not to give the money in the micro
transactions
but i think the important distinction to
make is that it doesn't impact
the actual
game the main game so in terms of like
not wanting to support microtransactions
you can not support them and just play i
still enjoy this game it's just a shame
that i guess like the the fairness of
that leaderboard seems to be skewed a
little bit and i think that that's why
it's possible that these leaderboards
will go the way of tomb raider
multiplayer
nobody cared right it kind of just was
this extension and it's possible totally
forgot
who knows how much people will care yeah
so is there any multiplayer apart from
that stuff that is no none there's
there's no like death match or anything
like that nobody cares yeah the only
multiplayer is that score that pops up
when you enter an area like it'll show
how your other friends and that's the
thing that we're talking about that's
like replaying um
a tomb for speed or something like that
and getting a score out of it and seeing
if you're the best at it excellent uh
last point i guess on this is obviously
this is an xbox one exclusive game for
here
for one year which
you know which is kind of synonymous i
guess with tomb raider because it was a
playstation exclusive game for a number
of years in the late 90s there was one
on like n64 and saturn i guess there was
never any tomb raider games for the
first three or four um
but it is like we're so not used to
exclusive games like in 2015 there's so
few of them especially third-party ones
um do you think that it's beneficial or
detrimental to tomb raider that it's an
exclusive game considering especially
the sales of the xbox one i guess yeah
it's really interesting because like all
the other exclusives that we see are
like from
like first party studios like until dawn
yeah i'm just thinking until dawn and
everybody's going to the rapture
bloodborne stuff like that tomb raider
is a sequel to a game that came out on
both platforms so in a way like i can
understand why players see this as a big
like players on ps4 see this is like an
fu we're getting this first
um
but at the same time like i think that
the exclusivity deal has made that game
look really pretty
i think that's sort of a reason why do
you think there's like a technical
benefit to only working with one i i
think that there's something i think
that there's a business back end that
you're not seeing right that
there's no doubt obviously that
microsoft was looking for exclusives to
help with the xbox and tomb raider is a
great one it's popular people like it
it's a well-known franchise what a great
place for a time to exclusive we'll give
you some money
now
crystal dynamics has probably paid for
tomb raider 3 before they even released
i mean who knows i don't know the exact
same
they've it's benefited them because
they've had increased development time
or whatever on it because now they get
this ability to
relax and make the game of their dreams
and i don't know as long as it's out
before christmas seriously well and so
pc is scheduled for uh early 2016.
and ps4 today is holiday whatever that
means could be i mean that could be
valentine's day
if we don't know which holiday yeah
saint patrick's day
that's a positive interpretation but
it's a timed exclusive it's not full and
you're giving that studio the time and
the resources that they need to be able
to maybe make the game better there's no
denying from what i've seen so far it's
a stunning game and it looks great i
i do worry that
that now tomb raider has been harmed
that the public is angry i see it all
the time people are angry
at tomb raider games but that's not
really fair and i think that that's up
to the public to kind of let that go and
realize a good game is a good game
nobody i don't know i don't know how
many xbox people who looked at
bloodborne and said what a [ __ ] game
like it was like you know you call it
what it is like it might it might be it
might be bad but it's not because it was
yeah it's just that like inherent
clanism with owning one console right is
that like if you did only own a
playstation 4 and you spent like 400 on
it and then this game that you played
the original one isn't coming out
because crystal dynamics wanted a bit
more cash to maybe make the game in
their dreams or maybe just to you know
give themselves a buffer like you gotta
understand why people are a bit arched
about it as well right yeah yeah yeah
definitely i'm like
he's kind of you know you know yeah i
can see it from their perspective as
well like i bought a playstation 4 and
i've been you know i'm a sony fan girl i
buy everything every multi-platform game
comes out on the playstation 4. and then
when they announced this for xbox it was
like oh
i guess like i'm gonna have to wait to
play it then i moved in with someone who
owns an xbox person
that's what you do yeah that's the
solution that's the san francisco weight
is if you don't have it you find a
roommate that has a boyfriend and then
you never move out i don't know yeah it
would never hurt my feelings but i i've
had an xbox since the beginning um
and you know what we
really needed this
you know what that's fine and uh
it's i just don't think it falls a long
way away oh god i forgot that game
existed until you mentioned it just now
that was interesting that was a long
time ago it was a long time so great
news for xbox one owners great news for
pc owners in 2016. right playstation
foreigners and it's time maybe look
better
than that in a year's time an extra
deposit it gives you time to really
figure out if you want it um it might
even come out on sale who knows but then
you have to avoid the internet for a
year for spoilers that's the problem
especially those of you watching this on
the playstation we don't know wanting to
see if you're going to buy it on ps4 in
12 months and let us know what you think
about tomb raider are you looking
forward to do you think the exclusivity
is a positive or a negative um and when
you're leaving your comment let us know
which console you own as well so you can
take that into account
we've got a bunch more stuff coming up
on today's show uh we're going to talk
about candy crush with our boy j hey in
a second and then we're going to talk
about four and four this is controllers
because we can talk about those next up
though uh sick ass trailer uh let's see
margaret in that goddamn persona 4
dancing game which i can't wait to get
my hands on
peggy 12.
perhaps this is fate as well
the time has come
i am prepared
welcome to the velvet room
my name is margaret
i'm here to accompany you on your
journey
expressing one's feelings through music
it looks as though it could be fun
excellent choice this may well heat me
up
nothing meaningless happens in this room
allow me to feel the reason i called you
special
then let us begin
let me entertain you
not a bad feeling at all
perhaps i shall ask for another song
persona 4 dancing all night
hello welcome back to the lobby we're
here to talk about business with justin
haywald how you doing i'm all about the
business business business business is
good i'm wearing a tie today you are
what's what's on your tie it's i got
this from studio ghibli it's a totoro
tie nice nothing says photos on it
nothing says business like some sweet is
it ghibli or ghibli
do you mind like the the actual
pronunciation yes
like i don't say that i'm asking the man
who speaks japanese fluently just ghibli
we're not here to talk about studio
jubilee we're here to talk about
activision purchasing kim.com
kim.com they bought kim.com kim
kardashian's website came back up she
does have a very successful mobile game
though but not as successful as the guy
who made mega upload is that was mega
dot com dot com and now activision own
kim.com it's amazing
so well no no no not kim this is
king.com oh king.com
rice king the guys make candy crush yes
and other games that you know really
well like candy crush soda saga okay
which
candy saga and owners of the words candy
and saga as the people who made the
banner saga are all too aware of those
so those were those were i think settled
out of court okay
the
the actual details of those will never
come to light they also were trying to
go after somebody who who was using the
word candy in a title somebody's
the developer of candy swipe which came
out before candy crush saga it's called
candy swipe candy swipe wow did they do
they try and take halloween to course
no there's no halloween in the title no
but candy but uh they go after comic
book characters for using the word crush
are you serious no no no that's not that
is not true i can't tell who knows but
let's talk about what we do know
activision has purchased this uh company
for an incredible amount of money how
much money and why do they do it so it's
over six billion dollars which is
which is an insane amount of money and i
think the reason that we think about it
like no matter what all these amounts of
money for these companies are crazy but
this one sounds especially
huge because recently disney bought star
wars for four billion dollars yeah that
means this is worth more to activision
than star wars is to disney look at this
who cares about this this guy there he
wishes he was playing candy crush this
guy yeah he's like oh man i'm going to
kill all the jedi because they bet me in
candy crush
and it's such like not only a film
franchise with star wars but
merchandising there's so many ways
they're going to make money from that
yeah the amount of money is is at the
end of the day really not that big of a
thing because candy crush even now when
it's on to decline candy crush and king
are not doing that great they still make
over a billion dollars a year they're so
you know activision is going to make
this back very quickly so it's it's not
really the matter of money but the fact
that they value it at that amount of
money that a publisher like activision
who has so many properties who has so
much that they can do they could buy
hundreds of smaller developers but
instead they went after the very biggest
features so well and what do you think
the reason is that they did that so is
it like either it's because they're
trying to
you know get a foothold into this
massive not emerging market mobile games
isn't emerging anymore someday these
mobile games will catch on it's very
much like it's bigger than than
mainstream games in terms of gross
revenue surely at this stage and then
just in terms of people who play it like
people who don't think of themselves as
gamers are actually gamers and they
spend more time and more money on them
than most of us do like
and
when you think about zynga and when they
think about a way like we think of a
whale it's like oh this person spent a
hundred or two hundred dollars in
microtransactions it's inga a whale is
someone who can spend thousands of
dollars a month on farmville yeah what
what are you buying uh if you're spam
it's like any other game that we play if
you spend enough time on it then you're
willing to buy the next dlc or whatever
like i'm not going to spend a thousand
dollars on file no matter how good
fallout 4 might be i'm not going to
spend a thousand dollars a month on it
so let's talk about i guess what are the
business reasons for this because king's
shares have jumped up something like 14
activisions have also had a spike today
like how much of this is just posturing
for shareholders how much of this is to
do with sort of how business is
perceived and not really like inroads
into like new markets are they going to
start making call of duty games on
phones like what what are we looking at
here i think those are the kinds of
things that we're going to see from our
perspective this seems like a ridiculous
thing it sounds like activision the call
of duty maker is buying candy crush saga
and they're not because candy crush is
just a small thing and that will
ultimately be gone and king knows that
king knows that they have kind of a
one-trick pony they've tried other games
yeah and like rovio like uh the
farmville developer zynga those games
have all failed nobody cares about those
games as much anymore they've tried to
diversify and they've just been
completely unsuccessful and king knows
that they need other properties they
need a way to distribute games
that that will reach a bigger audience
because they're on a downward trend and
activision on the other side has so many
huge titles like call of duty on the pc
side they have blizzard they have world
of warcraft and hearthstone they have
these really these games that capture
the core but they don't have a casual
audience and that's where ea has just
been killing them in the past couple of
years that ea as much as we might
disparage some of the things they do
they're really successful especially
with their mobile games a lot of people
play simpsons top out yeah
and this is activision's opportunity to
get a foot in that market without having
to start from the bottom like they're
basically taking not the game that's at
the top anymore because that's the clash
of clans type games age of whatever
agent age of war
those games are the current top game of
age but even now years after it's come
out candy crush is still like number
three and one of the others is number
six and this is a way for them to get a
lot of people really quickly and they
have access now to a huge swath of users
and a lot of money that they weren't
getting before from that market which is
kind of a
like i know people always throw at that
term but a blue ocean yeah like it is
endless people who don't think of
themselves as gamers play these games
your mom is someone who i don't know
about your mom like
we never talk about that one yeah yeah
we're doing i know yeah you know about
my mom but we don't talk about it but
my my mom in particular like loves these
kind of dumb games and she wouldn't like
you i wouldn't think of her as a
hardcore gamer but she'll spend hours
just like which is the problem games
have had
in perpetuity because the diff it's a
controller all these buttons like the
closest
you know how you know traditional game
core game whatever we refer to ourselves
as got to the mainstream was the wii and
the only reason for that was because it
was a remote control because people knew
how to use a remote control your
grandmother knew how to use a remote
controller so she could play tennis you
know and like i think that we're in a
really insular bubble we think the ps4
and xbox one are doing really well
they're doing better than the 360 and
the ps3 the pc is doing incredibly well
as well like getting more audience it
seems like but when you think of that in
the broader context like yeah it's doing
better than the previous consoles did
and it's still it's gaining acceptance
and it's making a lot of money
but not compared to something like
mobile gaming not compared to something
like the the ubiquity of tv and reaching
out to literally the entire world
because we like we love call of duty and
fallout and all of these other really
big franchises i can't wait to play star
wars battlefront but at the end of the
day that's actually a really small
percentage of the potential audience of
something that like oh i'm just going to
match these three colors i can you can
release that in any country and there's
no yeah no need to translate
localization there is localization there
is translating not to despair not to put
anything like that but you would but you
want the point of a child you can't read
and they can still figure it out they're
gonna figure out oh yeah put those
together i won so should we be worried
like the those of us who are in this
bubble those of us who are watching the
show and play these games that are
behind us and are excited about fallout
and stuff like you look at a company
like konami who's basically just said
sia to the you know traditional video
game industry because of their massive
money they have in their casinos pachiko
parlors there's a company like
activision which obviously still has
massive fingers in you know traditional
games but especially with blizzard and
they own some of the biggest franchises
but they're also like a far ways away
from the people who make grand prix and
pitfall like now they're getting into
this market which might be that much
more you know
revenue driving for them so like is this
something we need to be continuously
worried about because we're seeing so
many companies
which were near and dear to video games
the bigger ones at least spending more
time on this i mean when you say worry
about it like are we is this going to
change what these big companies do and
how they make money
yeah i'm sure like from that perspective
it's not going to be great there might
be a new metal gear game which is going
to be a pachinko parlor like this might
be the continuation of the metal gear
saga and in that sense yeah we're going
to lose these established franchises
that we might have a lot of nostalgia
for and a lot of something that's
holding on to it but at the same time
most of these companies are not getting
out of aaa gaming they still see this as
you're a valuable audience and we want
to create games for you it's really
expensive to make things like star wars
battlefront and these huge multi-year
multi-million dollars there's a reason
we don't see gta every year it's
expensive and it takes a lot of time and
and people and money but they're still
making those and those in the long run
still pay off but at the same time we
still have great indie developers who
are making
really wonderful experiences with really
small teams and that's the kind of thing
that's never going to go away and that's
the kind of way that we're going to i
think continue to get the experiences
that we love and it'll be really
memorable for for us from a gameplay
perspective and not having to worry as
much about how can we increase our
revenue this quarter over what it was
the previous quarter interesting times
justin hey well thank you for coming on
and explaining that crazy madness to me
and everyone watching uh king.com now
owned by the good people at activision
let us know what you think do you play
candy crush do you want none of your
call of duty on phones uh let us know in
the comment box below all right we'll be
back in a second to talk about the game
on everyone's lips is controller uh
right after this trailer for
see if i can remember
king think i can it's not king.com it's
not like don't tell me tay
what is it again five five nights oh
it's five nights at freddy's i read i
read
what
uh
that was [ __ ] weird
that was really fun that was really
weird game of the year 2016.
maybe it's a contender it is a container
we're gonna have to do that there's no
way that's the start of the fallout bit
we're gonna have to throw up the third
again no way
hey folks
we know what you wanna talk about we
know what we wanna talk about it's
fallout 4 this is peripheral look at it
here
it's the pip boy edition of fallout 4.
it's right here are you dumb and spent
120 on this like you're one of those
people um do you think this is ben's i
think
i think did you buy the pip-boy no no
okay i'm alone here there's someone else
in the offices i'm sure but it looks
cool it's right here look at it is it
worth a hundred dollars have you put it
on have you tried it is anything worth
it yes a lot of things are worth a
hundred dollars if he watched
gamespot.com you could see danny and i
shove his hand into it and realize it
opens it does okay so i'm biased because
i've already spent my money on this it's
on the wrong hand but it's upside down
but don't worry about it
um
let me i want i want your opinion what
do you think about it build quality what
do we think what about difficult this is
actually really nice like this is a
sturdier thing that i would have thought
i mean it's a hundred dollars i if this
were a piece it's 120 oh the knobs move
with the game all the time
hold on i'm so scared to knock this over
on to my laptop
does this not work today oh there we go
oh it lights up you put your phone in
yeah it'll have an app which will
connect up to the video game which is
out at some stage in the future yeah we
don't know and if we did we couldn't
tell you
uh and then you can you can play the
video game apparently with this on so
it's nice and light as well do you think
yeah it's not it's not heavy it feels
pretty there's velcro this feels like a
kind of metal that's the only metal
thing on it yeah in fact the one thing
about the build quality i wasn't so sure
is that we had a bit of trouble opening
it up for the phone yeah it was like try
again let's see okay so we had to push
it
oh no i'm going to break this
we had to push it we had to push it up
like this right here comes out yeah it
was there yeah and it can fit so many
kinds of phones it can fit this kind of
you're aware that this goes down
yeah i think that's what you do to pull
it up or something so it feels kind of
plasticky and when you're trying to like
fit it back in it doesn't like click
okay let me hear it let me see if i can
it's like it's so like you have i'm
afraid to break it yeah because it's
like
you kind of pop it up so that's where
the phone goes but when you put it back
down again it kind of catches this weird
part so you have to like
lift it up and tuck what i'm saying is
if you're taking this thing off and
putting it on again over and
keep an eye out over look if i try and
force this down like
does that as a fashion accessory yet
this is how i would want to use my like
i really oh that's easy you kind of push
it down and release it that way it seems
unstylish to get one of those hip
holsters but at the same time like i
don't like keeping my phone in my pocket
and you know smart watch i have a smart
watch here it's too small i can't do
anything with this this is useless
this is my phone on my wrist that's
amazing i mean no smart watches are all
about peacocking right so what's like
the ultimate smartphone peacock it's
this yeah this looks dumb nobody cannot
see that this does look dumb but imagine
if it was inside oh like oh it's not it
just falls so i have no idea like the
real test is gonna be how
how it works with the app because
blizzard have now or sorry not blizzard
bethesda have now it'll be the third app
they've launched this year yeah because
there's a new app that just came out yes
today follow chat that lets you chat did
you download it no i did can someone
else please download it as well so that
it's not just sending emojis to people
you can't see you can at least in the
the android version of it you can open
it up and then send those icons to other
uh to other services so we use it in the
work we use slack we do you can use send
those gifs we can do slack oh really
follow check great um
my question for you danny is when the
game comes out are you going to be
wearing this 24 7. i'm going to give it
a 21st wait when i'm playing the game 24
7. no we should see how long you can go
wearing this thing oh
i'll wake up in the morning and it'll be
like broken underneath my waist
like well you can take it off while you
sleep and you shower okay but
it'll be interesting i can't wait to see
what it's going to be like actually like
playing
or like for elongated because fallout's
a game you can easily play for like five
six hours yeah you get lost in it yeah
it seems like you would like
you could you could get like we don't
know if you have austin you get watching
followers
yeah
previous when you play fallout 3 you get
juice would get lost in it right yeah
yeah so presumably if you were to play
fallout 4 you would get lost in it for a
while does it make your hand go like i
would be afraid that it would be cutting
off circulation in my hand which could
have positive benefits as well but when
i'm stranger yeah
of course you don't actually have to
wear this you can just it can be a
collectible thing a decorative piece it
comes with a stand that's in there
which yeah do you want you take the
stand
but it's not the only dumb fault i think
foreign today no god damn it
um this controller oh boy is available
or not really available anymore which
cost me which was available for about 24
hours yeah it was it was sold pretty
quick um
yeah this cost 75.
nobody saw that nobody saw a photo this
got 75 bucks before shipping
normal controllers also are pretty
pricey they're 50 dollars yeah this has
xbox one so this takes uh
a headset just any regular headset it
does it has a new button it has a button
that lets you mute yeah and it lights up
when it's working
just so you know this isn't like a
sponsored thing we're just showing this
off so you can decide if you want to buy
this controller with its 10 foot usb
cable
for all your people who live in who have
like live in in the wasteland far away
from a from a television television i'd
buy this for that table that's an
awesome cable you want a cheap usb cable
with a free controller 10
10 10 feet it's it's wired only as well
and you can't see it but the buttons are
also somewhat customized yes for fallout
so when you press left there's a
controller button when you press right
there's a little person on person yeah
that's super cute it's kind of cute so
it and it feels all right it's like it
feels like a script to it no playstation
controller no no playstation version so
yeah i kind of feel like the fact that
this is wired as well means they're it's
really it's a pc controller you know
what i mean like it'll work out the box
with
windows 10 or windows 7 or 8 i think as
well and there's now a wireless adapter
for xbox one controller correct
it's 25 i think which i'm not sure if
works with this one but yeah so there
you go this feels nice that's all your
thing i can't wait to eventually play
the video game and then we can talk
about it yeah um but until then you get
to look at these wonderful things and
imagine yeah what it would be like and
we can we can show them to you as as
viewers to see if you want to purchase
them as well but i sure can't wait to
play fault you can't purchase either of
those can you like this is just all
aftermarket steps you're basically
saying hey you should go on ebay and buy
these for thousands of dollars
yeah they did a second run of the pip
boys i wouldn't be surprised if they
didn't well they did like a third one no
really
that was went over multiple times and
sold out each time the only way to get
these things now is by paying attention
fallout 4
stuff and this is the only way we're
able to do it so
look at our toys this is the thing
hey on a completely different note why
did you play over the weekend
i played
candy crush
did you
yeah i played the witcher 3 one of many
great games that came out in 2015.
all right that's the end of our episode
of the lobby today at x-ray career
justin hayward thank you so much for
coming on uh what are you doing for the
rest of the week at gamespot.com
playing video games okay
this weekend is blizzcon i'm gonna be
heading out with eric
thank god okay tell us about blizzcon
you can tell us about blizzcon right
you're able to tell us about blizzcon
we know that there's going to be movie
stuff
because they've showed the poster so
we're probably going to hear more about
that movie and i've i've heard from
sources that there's going to be news
about almost every game almost every
game every game that blizzard all those
almost everything that's a lot of games
will there be hearthstone news probably
i don't know what specifics there might
be but hopefully there'll be an
overwatch open weekend soon enough i
think that is probably a strong
possibility since people are playing it
now lots of people yeah yeah and of
course those fan favorites starcraft and
diablo yeah starcraft
what do you think about that eric tay
dead game erite is going to go with me
he was working in our back room there
yeah looking forward to that one um
thank you so much justin have a
wonderful time down in anaheim that
rhymed have a wonderful time
playing video games video games and
we'll be back next week to talk about
all the video games that come at them in
loot crate oh we've also got a loot
crate giveaway we probably should do
that and as well um
we're gonna talk about tourmater next
week maybe again yes perhaps yes we'll
talk about an upcoming bethesda game
yeah
are they putting something out i don't
know yeah oh yeah they're putting
something out yeah it's like it's like
an expansion for skyrim i think oh cool
yeah didn't they port it to xbox one for
something they did yeah they turned on
into something else i think oh yeah okay
yeah maybe it's nothing we got a loot
crate to give away we got a bunch of
loot crates to give away do you want to
hold this you're really good at holding
things dusty you can pass things to me
yeah yeah you can pass let's see what's
in this loot crate all right we have a
back to the future
dr brown
figure great scott alexa it's super cute
that's super cute i i'm probably a
bigger fan of this it's a doctor who
limited edition sonic spork it's this
pro i thought you were going to end with
sonic and i was like
doctor who's in sonic management so when
you need to eat food and you need you
don't know am i going to need a fork am
i going to need a spoon should it be
sonic it's a sonic spork that's pretty
good you know try and put that packaging
back together so we can give it to
someone put in your hand
you might win this one arlo crates come
with justin haywald's dna i know much
like everything here at gamespot.com um
be excellent to each other this is a
sweet uh bill and ted shirt which i am
now going to struggle to fold back in
the original way it was folded what else
do we have there a back to the future
hoverboard one to five scale replica you
cannot ride this
but you can look at it if you were a one
foot scale maybe yeah then maybe you can
maybe if you were one-fifth yeah a tiny
human and this is only one of many loot
crates that we're giving away today yes
there are so many things a bunch of
these this is the most recent one that's
a doctor who thing well this book
explains all of the neat things that
they do so loot crate does their monthly
grab bag of like a comic con in a in a
box yeah where you get random things
stuff and there's going to be more loot
crates that are i think more focused on
video game people that's the reason they
sent it to us uh there's going to be a
call of duty one uh and a mass effect
one
we don't know exactly what's going to be
in them sure
but they usually have some pretty cool
and exclusive stuff
cool and we've got a bunch of them that
to give away and we have a bunch of
these to give away not the massive ones
not the
later
uh
nerdy culture i don't know why you call
it stuff pop culture
non-video game stuff but we got about
yeah don't get it mixed up with the pip
boy things hopefully you get this one
yeah i like that i like the sonic sport
again
but if you want to win it all you have
to do is follow our game spot and
retweet what they done tweeted for your
chance to win one of those new crates
filled with swag close that one up you
gotta close up
gonna take all these things
all these iphone those are hip boy
holders or galaxy it also fits in that
it's been a show it's been a real show
we've nothing really to do to play or do
video coverage about no not really
happening this week so we should
probably just
keep doing the show maybe there's not
been a lot of big games no not really
slow end of the year nothing going on
slow week that's it
yeah all right
we're out of here we'll see you next
week where we'll talk about some goddamn
new common video games uh thanks to
everyone in the back for helping out
with today's show mary kish joshua eric
tay don muhorrik and everyone else who
helps put this thing together we'll be
back next week tuesday 2 p.m pacific
stay doing gamespot.com in the meantime
for all the updating news on i believe
there's some call of duty stuff coming
later this week with blizzcon of course
on the weekend and then
early next week we'll talk about an
upcoming bethesda game until then have a
great week and we'll see you next time
you